بلدي اوصل الامور باعتقادك الى هذه الدرجه
من الغضب ورد فعل الشرطه الفرنسيه كيف
تفسره
[تصفيق]
النتيجه باستم
رار المشكله التي وقعت في فرنسا ان ال
الجميع كان يعتقد انه الصعود الاقتصاد
كيف يتضرر منه المهاجرون فقط لكن للاسف
الذي يحدث اليوم يؤكد
لانقاذ وكذلك اهم من فرنسا
مواطنين سوف يتاخر بصعود
والدليل على ذلك ان عمليه من العمليه التي
اطلقه
الاجانب وهم الاخلاق هذه المره ادت الى
الى توتر كبير والى ثم وتقدي هذا الشكل
الحديثه جدا من اللاعب جدا جدا
اليوم هو رساله واضحه لجميع النقط
السياسيه والاعلاميه وكذلك الفكريه
واصحاب حتى المؤسسات الاعلاميه رجال
الاعمال بالناس يجب مواجهه خطاب اليمين
متفرج في اليمين في خطاب وسموماسات والا
فان السلم الاجتماعي في فرنسا وكذلك امن
الفرنسيين وامن الفرنسا كدوله وشعب فيتعرض
الى
اهتزازات كبيره جدا والذي يحصل يوم هو
افضل واكبر
هجوم امس حتى همم
تتجنب هذا المشهد الذي نراه اليوم
اظن ان ان ال الذي يحصل اليوم هو عمليه هو
انقلاب في الوضع يعني الذي يحصل يوم ان
هذه المظاهرات هذه الاتهامات بانهك
استخبارات تركيه وراء هذا العمل
العمليه كما حصلت في ولايه يعني الذي حصل
ان لا يمكن الواحد من اليمين
يشرح الاجانب ان يتعامل مع دوله مثل تركيا
والكل يعلم بان تركيا لدى الدوائر الرسميه
على انها اكبر الاعداء الخارجي
اوضاع كان يجب التعامل معها اليوم الحكومه
لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا الذي يحكم الان من
المظاهرات والتقريب هذا اظن انه لم يفيد
في شيء وهو حتى يؤمن عمليه
قتل الاجانب هذه كانت على الاكراد قبل قبل
اشهر والسنوات كانت على في مسجد همم حصلت
في اماكن اخرى لا اظن انك استهدافهم
الاتراك تاكراد ولكن ما انت اجانب الاساسي
لذلك الحكومه يبدا تتعامل مع الوضع ليس مع
يحدث اليوم انها تتعامل مع الاسباب لا مع
النتائج